president biden's homeland security
secretary told lawmakers on capitol hill
the situation on the southern border is
difficult
but he would not call it a crisis his
comments came as u.s customs and the
border patrol are dealing with a huge
influx of immigrants far more than a
year ago though it's still less than the
peak levels
of 2019. maria villarreal visited some
of them who have been waiting for months
to plead their case
maria good morning to you
good morning gail right now the biden
administration is slowly starting to let
thousands of asylum seekers into the u.s
to wait for their hearings that's a big
change from the trump era
where they were forced to remain in
mexico and yet still
a lot of people are stuck across the
border right now
waiting they have told us that they are
in squalor conditions in fact we went
over the border for to see firsthand
exactly what they are dealing with
as they wait out their cases my dad was
a drug dealer my oldest brother was a
drug dealer
a reformed gang member turned ordained
minister
abraham barbary crosses daily from
brownsville texas into matamoros mexico
where he opened a bible school and
hip-hop church in between the songs we
would
you know share the good news share the
gospel in the last year this father of
four helped
minister to thousands of migrants living
in this makeshift camp near the
international border
this was video taken three weeks ago
outside the camp
and this is what it looks like today
it's been abandoned
most of the migrants waiting here were
allowed to cross into the u.s
to start the asylum process but nearly
60 were left behind with nowhere to go
when the camp was shut down
by the mexican government we were just
waiting for those 56
asylum seekers to cross the border and
close
the shelter because this is just a
temporary shelter
but people started coming you know into
matamoros and people who were
already here and they just came and we
just couldn't
you know say no this is actually a
church
school that has now been converted into
a shelter for migrants
have a lot of people from a lot of
different areas one thing they have in
common is they want to be able to have
their chance to go into the us
ask for asylum
so she said that's where she sleeps and
her friend
uh sleeps there school rooms are now
bedrooms
and this parking lot is now a part-time
playground
everyone is hoping to explain why they
deserve a chance at requesting asylum in
the united states
they say it's confusing they want at
least to be able to tell their story to
someone in the government
and they're very frustrated because
nobody is listening
i mean their level of desperation is at
an all-time high
when it comes to what's happening across
the border the
influx of immigration immigrants is
there an end in sight
i don't i don't think so at least not
for now as a matter of fact i think it's
going to increase because
right now the people in south america
central america
and south mexico for some reason they
think that the borders are going to be
open
resources and money are exhausted in
mexico
and the government has little incentive
to help the u.s care for these migrants
anymore
do you think that the mexican federal
government wants to help these people
i don't think so i i really honestly
think that
because of this three years a very
intense immigration
processes and dialogues i think that the
mexican government is tired of it
do you feel like it's your duty to do
this so as a christian
to me this is what i'm supposed to be
doing right i'm just doing what i think
i'm supposed to be doing
so we met groups from cuba latin america
even an indigenous group from chiapas
mexico who told me they were fleeing
cartel violence right now we do
understand that more asylum seekers will
be allowed to come through
this port of entry in hidalgo texas but
the process will be very slow and these
people
are very tired of waiting tony you can
understand why maria thank you very much